[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome to algebra in the most
remote corner of the Seychelles where
the Sun is just setting after an
incredible three days live deep down in
the Indian Ocean has been absolutely
fascinating what we've seen at more than
250 metres below and in the next hour
we'll take you right back down so let's
start at the start with our first
descent into the deep and a moment in
broadcasting history with both of us
heading down the deep ocean life
[Music]
I'm Debra is famous for its remoteness
and for its very treacherous currents
anything could happen so don't go
anywhere sit back enjoy the viewers like
we are and let us take you down to the
depths very cozy in here getting warmer
by the minute I have to say and one
person that I'm already very well
acquainted with is my pilot for this
mission Randy holt thank you so much for
having us
and well what an extraordinary working
environment you have it's amazing down
here you know every dive is different
and we get to go places where people
have never been before explain where we
are to change the cameras which I can do
we've tucked herself into a crevice if
we are 135 meters in yeah we're kind of
leaning against the edge of a cliff an
underwater cliff
we were fighting some down drafts and
some up drafts when we got to this
position so we just kind of perked
ourselves on a Ledge and there trying to
stay stationary and I should give you a
proper title of course you are an
Aquanaut if an astronaut explores space
you explore the deep yes
you know where an inner space it's a
whole new place down here and you know
it's a 3d environment so we're always
moving around
where we are how how we're moving
through the water column are we lighter
are we done the heavier exactly it's
it's it's amazing to watch you with all
the controls and as you said you're
flying these submersibles you're not
driving them and as you said the oceans
make up 97% of the habitable space on
planet Earth which gives you both a
sense of the depth of the oceans but
also that 3d environment that Randy was
talking about we have joined an
expedition led by the scientist of the
natural mission their aim is to perform
a deep ocean health check to map to
chart to sample to see perhaps what no
one has ever seen before and even search
for those rarely seen species lurking in
the shadows the dream perhaps of a
sixgill shark or even a Celia Camp the
Dino fish thought to be extinct for
millions of years and crucially to see
what is happening to that often colorful
coral as it faces unprecedented threats
it is so important as habitat and home
to millions of species the big question
for the scientists is could the deeper
ocean be a refuge from the dangers of
climate change and even from plastic
pollution that we've talked so much
about at sky well we are not alone down
here this is someone the red one
although it's been showered by this
downdraft of sediment which you will
hear the team referred to as a murderer
out there we can see them is sub to the
yellow at the yellow one yes the yellow
one we have the red one I've already
done at which they call Kensington in
there is the principal scientist on this
amazing expedition dr. Lucy Woodall from
the nectar mission and piloting her sub
is Robert
the scientists have been coming down as
I said very delicately trying to take
samples of some of the deep corals that
we've seen some of the the fans that are
absolutely beautiful certainly and they
very delicately take some of those and
back up to the surface
and up on the surface if we peer up we
can see the outline of the mothership
above and up there is my colleague mark
austin mark we're up here we're safe and
well and amazing I just can't believe
that we're seeing you and hearing you
like this just I mean it just gives us a
sense of how you feeling right now well
from being very hot it's just quite
extraordinary just before we came on air
we saw a white tip shark very near help
there was it to think random oh it was
three meters away 20 meters away from us
you never know quite what you're going
to see all above us it gets more and
more blue down beneath us it's like a
murky brown color it looks very very
forbidding I have to say and so the deep
beneath us we already went down there to
about a hundred and seventy five meters
but above it looks pleasantly light I
can see small fish dancing on this rocky
outcrop just above and obviously it's
nice to have the company of the
principal scientist Lucy Woodall can we
talk to the yellow sub let's try hello
Robert and Lucy can you hear us
Kensington Kensington Omega
[Laughter]
copy that four six nine on her starboard
side hello Lucy what have you seen so
far down here to make you excited that
this is a healthy environment for marine
animals
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
Wow right down
[Applause]
Lucy thank you so much for the moment
thank you the electron mission which is
what we are part of is happening in
these Seychelles in the western Indian
Ocean the least explored yet the most
threatened of the world's oceans and
we're diving off our debris and idyllic
at all
700 miles southwest of the main
Seychelles island of maje were actually
though closer to Africa some 400 miles
away from the coast there and around 270
miles northwest of Madagascar the
visibility here is amazing and the
sphere of perspex gives us a 270 degree
view you can look above you can look
even below where our feet off and you
can look left and right as we do all the
time you must be very tempted to look
around you all the time oh yes there's
so many things in fact if you stay in
one spot for 10 to 15 minutes you see
something you never saw before well we
can also control the cameras down here
as I said we are perched on a rocky
outcrop there it is driving like Yap try
some nights
[Music]
there we are we are literally hanging on
to the seamount face the wall that
builds up to the at all if you imagine
this was an old mountain that has
gradually sunk to leave this enormous
Lagoon in the middle of it you can fit a
sizably fit Manhattan in New York in the
middle of the lagoon above us and that's
partly why we have such difficulty with
the currents because at certain times of
the day all the water floods out and all
the water floods in and a reminder to
that we really don't know what is
beneath this no one have got what part
Moss this morning has ever been deeper
than where we are and we don't know
where what we're going to see where
would we're going to shift direction
suddenly now what is very important to
remember here is that there are a number
of zones people used to think that it
was just the shallows and then they
would think it was the depths and now
gradually they're realizing that there
are many stages in between the zones are
changing so for example you get the
scuba zone which is not to 30 perhaps 40
if you're very experienced here it would
probably be naught to 20 meters because
there is no decompression unit here very
difficult to get help
so most people diving here if they're
allowed you have to very careful permits
would only get to 20 meters
the first of these zones then where the
scuba divers go is called the alte
photic zone known as the sunlit zone
enough light penetrates this upper layer
of water for reef-building corals to
thrive it's also the most exposed to the
impacts of human activity so the next
own down which is where we are now is
the Mesa photic zone 40 meters to about
150 meters the middle light zone it's
called often regarded as the start of
the twilight zone at this level sunlight
starts to dwindle corals become flatter
and thinner they are more likely to be
plankton eaters then use the pledget
synthesis of the algae inside them and
here you begin to see the white tip reef
sharks which I mentioned we saw just
before we came on air you're more likely
to see the potato groupers and I'm livin
with makes them mostly some of those as
well and you might see that this is
perhaps a refuge from some of those
dangers that I mentioned
next is a new zone that people have
found they thought beneath us the life
would tail away with his very little
light from the surface and it became
increasingly difficult to see life
beneath us but now confirmed in a
previous nectar omission in fact there
is the rare e photic zone 150 metres
down to 300 metres the term that
scientists use to describe rare amounts
of like rare fot that our mission on the
whole of this week's coverage in deep
ocean life is to get to the bottom end
of this zone 300 metres the zone largely
unexplored and likely there are may be
thousands of marine creatures down there
that have never really been seen before
300 metres is the maximum that this
submarine can dive to what would happen
if we went below
dimitra's well we don't want to do that
but they are designed and pressure
tested with some safety factors in there
so it's actually been tested beyond 300
meters but
what are we sitting down here we're
seeing very small fish you'd think
perhaps they were more like small marine
fish missing a large number of sea fans
some a little bit difficult to see in
this image way of presenting to you now
but we will move around very shortly
we're seeing some with coral a lot of
thing lines they're famous because they
can't retract their tentacles if you
imagine that coral is a food for large
numbers of animals most corals try to
whip in their tentacles certainly to get
out of the way and parrotfish famously
are they bite through coral with a fused
front teeth and that is in fact what
gives us our beautiful sandy beaches and
some of this debris we've had dropped
down I mean this red submersible is
completely covered in that marine snow
isn't it some of that is probably washed
away from the coral atoll and drops down
on us has been quite amazing actually we
are broadcasting live to you from the
Indian Ocean at a depth of around 816
feet which is 250 meters it is the
deepest we have been yet on deep ocean
life and if the communications hold and
the currents are favourable we could
possibly go a bit deeper I can tell you
I broadcast from some pretty remote and
amazing places in my time but none quite
so remote or amazing as this let me just
show you the picture here and it's quite
unnerving in some ways it's like we've
descended into it all together sort of
alien world which of course we have it's
like a moonscape but the bottom of the
sea at this step there's barely a
glimmer of sunlight what you're seeing
are the lights of the submersible the
technical name for where we are as the
rarer photic zone and if you saw our
program yesterday with Anna well this is
a now
about a hundred meters deeper and what's
so exciting about this is that we are
probably the first down here it's
largely unexplored unmapped an
unsurveyed and so in some ways it is a
privilege to be here the job today the
task today is to establish the impact of
man on the ocean deep down here and on
the surface so we are on something of a
hunt today even down here I should to
say the species down here evolved over
millions of years long before we walked
on earth yet the threats facing them now
are unprecedented but here even in these
pristine seas is there a threat from
plastic pollution coral bleaching and
climate change well that's what we hope
to find out in the next hour we want to
reveal just a little bit maybe about
what's really happening in the deep and
if we start with one thought in mind it
must be this that a recent study by New
Castle's University scientists suggested
there is more than three hundred and
ninety-three million tons of plastic in
our oceans but only two hundred and
forty six thousand tons is on the
surface that means that 99% our 99.9
percent is suspended in the water around
us it's lying in the bottom it'll buried
in the seabed and it's a quite a
frightening a frightening thought Randy
and I mean how much different is this
from where you were yesterday hundred
meters
further up well we've gone a lot deeper
today and the landscape has changed
quite a bit so instead of seeing that
vertical wall we're seeing more of a
slope of hard bedrock and these broken
boulders that were clinging to right now
yeah and we're having to cling on
because the slope is so sharp here and
what about being down here you know it's
very deep as I say it's 250 meters the
pressure is what something like you know
325 times what we're seeing on the
surface down here and the temperature
down here is 12 degrees Celsius where I
was at the top on that ship where I was
yesterday
it was you know 34 degrees what kind of
debt and this submersible we're in I'm
not getting worried what kind of depth
in this withstand well even though it's
designed so 300 meters they pressure
test it to 25% beyond that and designed
for even deeper so like we say I mean we
can go to any job yeah but the pressure
on us now I mean if we tried to it's
it's so much that we couldn't open the
hatch if we wanted to in fact I could
undock it and there's no way you could
open that hatch there's so much force
holding it
right and I said at the beginning we may
try and get deeper in this submersible
only now how much deeper could we go we
could go down to 300 meters yeah
and I should give you I'm just looking
down actually in a very very taut no I
really want to go any further we're
having the most extraordinary journey
over this moon skate down here that
we're still at 815 feet so just under
250 meters and we are seeing the most
extraordinary some coral all sorts of
reef fish down here and it is really
something else and they're just deeply
there you can see in the distance
through that the other submarine of just
putting your lights on there and we're
just trying to get closer to that
submarine so we can be realigned with it
but Randy I mean what just watch explain
what are we trying to do here right now
we're just trying to get keep our comms
up and we're watching the Kensington
they're doing a science survey so the
other sub that yeah so they have these
stereo cameras and I'm just trying to
kind of avoid the rocks here and
come up behind them we are though I can
see now at yeah about two fifty to sixty
meters down so you can understand some
of the problems that we're having so
maneuvering the submersible and at the
same time staying in alignment would be
led receiver is the issue that we're
having at the moment coming up next how
deep ocean live brought together science
and technology and the surreal feeling
as we plunge down in the subs
[Music]
you see the other son
that is amazing
my sky
well as well as the deep itself that
journey to and from are quite amazing
you start off tipping down in these
submersible into the blue and instead of
seeing marine life you literally just
see blue you're in open sea ready to go
Oh see the other server that is amazing
by sky and you descend down through that
and you get to 200 250 meters and it's
suddenly dark the sunlight goes and just
a glimmer glimmer of sunlight but most
of I then is submersible light
[Applause]
[Applause]
it lights up this very eerie kind of
world that is like a moonscape at under
the sea and it's unnerving yeah you want
to go east or west then you realize on
the rocks all these living creatures you
think all there's nothing down here
then suddenly he puts the light close-up
on on a rock you see it's teeming with
life and with living things and then you
realize that you're in this other world
or world within a world and it's not
your world is it it's a rocky outcrop
you can see this at the bottom of the
sea mount coming up our current depth is
four four three feet and then the
journey up I have to say probably my
favorite beard
as you ascend you start to see this
glossy appearance as if the sea is above
you
and you start seeing these giant bubbles
rising up with you there's nothing now
and then you pop out and see the ships
an amazing feeling I did think even
coming to the surface is amazing because
you're coming through you're surrounded
by bubbles and they're getting bigger
and bigger and bigger McGann next thing
you know it's like you hope you're
getting rocked up and down and you pop
out in the bright sunlight and you see
the ship here and it's not washing them
down and you feel like you feel like
from the depths up to the light you feel
that contrast
all of it all of it usually different
all the way through and they hit the
bottom which is my sanding yeah and then
we are finding deeper parts and little
communities to see see fans small fish
bloopers be the Sharks a clue from quite
early on the shark didn't want to seem
to go
but they're going to investigate who we
are what we are they've never seen us
before and we drop down to
yes just about it might look easy but
there was lots of extraordinary
technology that made it happen well as
you saw our submersibles headed down
towards 300 meters below the ocean it's
at that level that sea salt pressure and
a lack of electromagnetic waves stifle
any traditional broadcasting methods so
a receiver was lowered between the
submersibles and the ocean zephyr to act
as an antenna LED lights on each of the
submersibles sent audio and video
information to this platform which in
turn transferred the information to the
mothership by a cable our pictures were
then sent by satellite back to our HQ in
London and then onto your screens
for that communication between the two
subs I mean that was
one of the most extraordinary parts
about this whole thing
the communication between the so close
fine dancers a ballet if you like where
we had the roadblock on a wire that was
giving us that two shot two submersibles
but also we have that weight depress
that all the technology got two things
on a line in water with currents on a
steep cliff and then the subs so it was
like a puppet show but masterminded like
a ballet out also with the ship is a 90
meter ship here and that was positioning
to two meters here and a meter there
just so we could make that connection
and I hope the connections that we were
able to create help people see the ocean
in a profoundly different way
just finally are you sure it'll work of
course I'm sure
we are here take your heavier doubts I
think the fun of what we're doing and
the excitement of what we're doing is
that we're pushing boundaries we are
exploring we are entering the unknown a
by net and by definition we are making
things up as we go along that's what's
so exciting about this this was a risk
for us there's a risk for you as sky to
do it we came together and said you know
what let's give this a shot because if
we succeed then we are gonna yeah we're
gonna change we change the the baseline
here now everyone else that follows
needs to do this and better we've just
like reset the dial and I think that's
what's exciting about it I hope you know
what we've done is great it's how people
reconnect with the ocean and
bringing pitches free images putting
people at the heart of the story was the
journey into the deep I believe is the
next umbrella gonna see for Humanity the
most critical journey of exploration
that we take we've been looking at what
we need to be together
now we weren't here just to look at what
was happening in the deep but on the
surface - yes and that meant me having
to spend the night in a tent on the
island here with lots of these this is a
robber crab they wreak havoc I have to
say that I did not sleep last night
because this these things lots of them
try to get into my tent literally tried
to unzip it I think at one point they
come they smell they have extraordinary
sense of smell they can smell the food
that we were cooking and there were
hundreds of them on the beach last night
15 different sorts of land crabs here
thank you Jesse for bringing that one
we're going to get another orange one in
a man minute I think 15 different land
crabs on this island just shows there
are so many different species here that
are thriving because human beings are
not this is not a place for mammals
there are some rats some cats not on
Malabar which is one of the four islands
of the Aldabra atoll all surrounding
this Lagoon none on here so no mammals
means other species flightless birds and
other creatures and we were privileged
enough to see a a female turtle battling
yesterday a green turtle battling to try
and make one of these holes where they
lay their nests it's exhausting work for
them it was grunting as it tried to do
and in fact the one we saw tried three
different holes and Lindsey I know it
was you that worked me up to come and
see this
I say woke up it's almost impossible to
sleep when robber crabs are trying to
get into your into your tent and the
work that the Turtles do to get up here
to fight their way through and we think
that the turtle we saw laying last night
her eggs have all gone there was an army
of robber crabs literally circling
around her just waiting for the
opportunity to get in and take those
eggs this morning I've watched one of
our wonderful endemic species on our
Dabra which is the flightless rail also
wandering around with hatchlings in its
mouth they look dead so presumably they
were ones that emerged from a nest too
far back on the beach and they just
couldn't make it if they emerge in
daylight they risk obviously just being
dehydrated and dried up in the Sun so
everything is out to get those poor face
it's a real battle against the odds
we'll walk towards Craig and towards
Stephanie as well and see if we can see
the actual well they've nearly all gone
there and the Flies are all buzzing
around them aren't they
this is the nest that eventually our
turtle tried to lay her eggs I say our
turtle we watched her for about an hour
and a half and if you go right down
there if you can see all the Flies look
at those eggs they've already gone and I
think we don't know if she was just too
exhausted to cover them too exhausted to
cover her hatchlings so they stay in
there and the robber crabs would have
gone in and sucks out all the goodness
and that this one thing that's really
struck me about both the marine
environment and being underwater things
like black tip reef sharks that are
nocturnal that the fact that the reef
allows hiding places for all the smaller
fish the predator and prey aspect of the
natural world is truly shocking when you
say it like this I think the problem is
in a lot of the environments that we're
used to encountering predators have
often been eliminated or are much lower
density that may would be in an intact
place like this and that is one of the
things that you've really noticed is
that the number of apex predators but
that's actually a sign of a really
healthy ecosystem the system needs
predators and certainly on coral reefs
that's been shown that coral reefs with
healthy shark populations are generally
much healthier what is really
distressing is when you see animals that
have been caught in marine bits and
bulbs and in fact I know that Seychelles
Islands Foundation has filmed one a
loggerhead turtle they passed by here
they're not really
they don't base themselves they do that
here but they're on migration through
here and in fact we have lots of
incredible animals that just come by our
diver and it's important staging pace
for them there are humpback whales that
come through here which you can see
breaching off the settlement beach whale
sharks there's a whole additional fauna
that is just migratory here and the
pictures were of the loggerhead wrapped
around in fishing gear and in fact some
of this sort of stuff is the probably
part of this fish aggregation devices
it's really common to use this technique
for tuna fishing so if you're thinking
about your tuna sandwich later today
there is a very good chance that it will
be a fish aggregation device that has
been used but fishing is really
important to the Seychelles economy so
the question is should it be better
regulated rather than banned are there
ways that these fish aggregation devices
could be used better better for species
so that doesn't get cut off and left to
just float in and this is part of the
stuff that the turtles that you see a
court in the green turtles here are a
success story aren't they tell us why
there are an enormous success story they
were hunted here in in the in the old
days where this island was exploited but
since that time they've been very
heavily protected since the late sixties
early seventies and we've really watched
their populations booming and that's a
fantastic thing to see what we don't
want to see is that going into reverse
or into decline okay for the moment
thanks very much indeed giant tortoises
giant tortoises so many that's what they
they're 150,000 that compares with the
population in the Seychelles of 93
around 93 thousand gwon animal that has
been eating that plastic is right in
front of us there a giant Aldabra
tortoise
land tortoises like this have been
around for 200 million years and only in
two places in the world are they now
endemic and that is the Galapagos
Islands and here on Aldabra atoll a
hundred and fifty thousand of them their
story is remarkable they were the chosen
food of sailors they can go for months
without food and water they would bundle
them into their ships put them down in
the ship's hold leave them there and
then eat them when they needed to here
on Ord Abra they were almost wiped out
by 1900 and certainly Charles Darwin is
amongst those people who've tried to
save the Aldabra giant tortoise it's an
extraordinary thing to see them here in
the wild it is of course just after noon
here the tortoises need to get out of
the Sun they need to because they could
cook to death quite literally and dr.
Lindsey Turnbull is here with me now it
is so amazing to live amongst them one
slip right by my tent last night and
when they fall asleep it's as if they've
expired they can't go on any further yes
they remind you of a sort of clockwork
toy they only have so much life in it
and eventually at the end of the day the
clock
quick just runs down and they just stop
wherever they happen to be and you'll
find them there in the morning will now
wake up again and if we look down here
we've got another endemic species a
mother and her young this is the Aldabra
flightless rail if you think of the dodo
the famous dodo it's probably just about
hidden now in there they are amazing
they're very friendly they're not used
to people it just shows wildlife not
used to people there's the young chick
that's been eating the turtle hatchlings
today we've seen them running off with
them off the beach and that is
extraordinary to see because there's no
other flightless bird left in the
western Indian Ocean that's right and
flightless birds are one of those great
casualties of humans arriving on Islands
this is why this is such an
extraordinary place it's an island lots
of things can't get here and in
particular and then alien predators
can't get here naturally and that allows
all kinds of mad experiments and
evolution to take place including
flightless birds
unfortunately when humans arrived as you
were just describing they came here to
harvest the tortoises and to harvest the
turtles but what they brought with them
were rats for cats were pigs were goats
and those things that actually
devastating to Island wildlife and
that's one of the big things that SIF is
always trying to do is to eradicate any
invasive species that have got here now
that burrows not quite pristine because
we still have rats and cats on some
islands although not on Malabar and yeah
so it's it's good to see this guy he is
so tame like you say is one of the real
great characters of this island going
back to the giant tortoises are there
too many of them because 150,000 we can
see if we look at this there's some of
the trees as well
they eat absolutely everything they can
a little tree here no lower branches
because they literally live off
vegetation don't they they need
everything they can and actually in the
dry season they can starve to death
can't they yes absolutely and I don't
know if your camera is able to pan
around but you can see some shells
behind right that's exactly what happens
to them they simply have expired perhaps
they've overheated perhaps they weren't
able to find enough food and we don't
they're not predator limited so you have
to you have to ask yourself when you ask
other too many of something what limits
their population size and and basically
animals are limited by one or two things
they're on
the limited by food or their limited by
predators these things don't really have
a lot of predators as adults but they
are limited by the number of food the
amount of food but that doesn't mean
there's too many of them and you know
that as long as they're replacing
themselves then the population is stable
and this population is stable yes and in
fact we've got some flip-flop in some
excrement I think over there which will
get them and I just want to show you
before we go there this is the tortoise
skull quite small
these massive leg bones as well that
hold them up and you can see beyond this
carapace that line here the weight they
have to carry and the hip bone over
there as well as it sort of begins to
disintegrate it's amazing to see these
just lying around and in fact you do see
some of them dead they see Turtles dead
as well some of the mothers that simply
can't get back to the water in time that
absolute exhausted they come overnight
they sit in the Sun and if they don't
get back to the water they will die same
with these guys as well if they don't
get into the shade and the midday Sun we
saw them under the trees there they
literally will cook inside they'll cook
to death terrible and they're so
slow-moving as well that you just don't
know if they're gonna get back into the
Sun in time so show us what we've got
here then yes well this is a tortoise
poo and you know it's a tortoise pee
because it doesn't appear to be able to
digest things terribly well so we can
see whole dead leaves in here and that's
just the natural food of the tortoise
they will have a go at pretty much
anything and that's the problem with
this because if I turn it over you can
see that this tortoise has been chomping
away on one of those flip-flops that our
team has just been cleaning up so the
tortoises do go down onto the beaches
they will have a go at anything they
will scavenge away at things and they
just don't understand that this is not
food and they will eat it and the colors
also attract them so we did some
experiments with coloured rice balls
actually to find out which colors they
particularly liked and red and yellow
colors were particularly attractive to
them but as you can see they seem pretty
keen on these green flip-flops as well
we've got the team here from the
Seychelles Islands Foundation and from
the Aldabra cleanup project who have
been cleaning this beach for us during
our coverage on deep ocean live and
talked us through some of our your
toothbrush there Jessie what are the
sort of things you found here I mean
everything in anything you can imagine
that's ever been made of plastic these
are just some toothbrushes you might
these brands anything this is a part of
a North Face flip-flop this is a
packaging of a water bottle it's come
from Malaysia this is all the things
that I find interesting this is some
orange juice wrapping that's also coming
from let's come from Indonesia oh and
this is a king chess piece one of our
one of our other volunteers has managed
to collect basically a full chess set
just from cleaning the beaches because
anything you've ever made a plastic if
we don't currently have a solution on
how to recycle plastic it's going to end
up somewhere best-case scenario right
now is that ends up in landfill but we
do know that these chemicals are
leaching out of the landfills into our
water so even if we put these plastics
in landfill it could still end up the
plastic the chemicals could still end up
in the sea it's almost like we need a
complete rethink of not only our
consumption of plastic but isn't our
entire consumer society isn't it and
that and that's really where we're at
you you're one of those PhD students
from Oxford University who have joined
the a debris cleanup what have you got
out of it and to be with local say shell
while people as well to come here and
try and make this pristine place more
pristine absolute roller coaster and
life-changing experience these guys are
amazing
I've made friends for life I've also
really struggled with the heat I mean
coming fro it was snowing when we left
Oxford and came here and it's sometimes
35 degrees you know very high humidity
working in the hot Sun but I can feel
like that's how it should be to get the
privilege of coming here when you're not
so sure was the dream for say shalwar
people to come here most can't so if you
are British to be able to come here
should have a good reason to come here
and it should be hard and it's and it's
really bad that's so hard to get this
plastic off Tracy Mahoney Thank You
Craig Franco you were born in the UK but
you are say shallow I lived there now
amazing trip for you as well to try to
restore and I know as Tracy was saying
people in the Seychelles dream dream
dream of coming 12 abro don't they
absolutely this is like winning the
lottery for anyone from the Seychelles
so
yeah coming here is a once-in-a-lifetime
opportunity
very privileged to be here and I think
for us as well it's amazing to be a part
of the solution as well somewhere as
pristine as this place should be it's
it's despairing to see it like this but
it's great to be a part of the solution
particularly as a as a social person as
well this is on this beach and another
very small beach up here and have to say
this is really the whole of this
coastline the northern coastline is made
up of coral ancient coral isn't it so
there's only a couple of beaches so this
is what you found just in small small
areas it's worth remembering so this is
something that we've done in less than
an hour small group of us and this is a
drop in the ocean compared to what we've
been doing down in the South but we've
got flip-flops as you can see I think
we've got two or three bags of
flip-flops in 50 minutes already we've
got some pet bottles here also from all
around the world some branded as well
some have been in the ocean for so long
as well they're starting to degrade and
turn into fragments
we have miscellaneous items consumables
glass bottles as Josie said anything and
everything that you can imagine we're
finding here thank you so much all of
you for your help your hard work this
morning we really appreciate it
keep up the good work this is the most
extraordinary place to come the number
of flip-flops there really underlines
the problem of plastic pollution but
will those pictures make a difference
next how deep ocean live made a
generation of schoolchildren sit up
given their importance why aren't there
more marine reserves well that is a very
good question
I've got small children with me from up
and down the country you've got some
really pressing questions for our team
in the Seychelles about climate change
biodiversity and of course sharks yeah
and I think that one's for you Ally
because you've seen so many there where
you are we're starting to call you the
shark whisperer here at sky yeah I know
I'm going to been dreaming about them I
have to say Sarah Jane lovely to see all
the children they're absolutely
brilliant Andy is piloting and below the
ocean this morning that they are sitting
there having a great time that exploring
new things down there we've got some
quickfire questions for you and let's go
to George us off the last question so
Joel now has to hand to Lucy from new
battle highs got a question what's the
weirdest type of species you've found
under war the weirdest ones I think some
of the scientists has seen have to be
the sunfish it was about 2 meters big
Louise saw it she's on the on the ship
right now at 200 meters and I think
they're the weirdest thing because they
sort of swim around like this and the
potato grouper who follows up to the
surface some of the weirdest things I've
seen are things that don't look like
anything you've seen before these
jellies that glow and they form these
colonies and you know they might be the
absolutely amazing I mean it's wonderful
to see all of this and a mark went even
deeper obviously as you continue to
remind me to 257 meters I don't know
what you saw down there that that
tickled you
13 metres deeper than you at the moment
the thing that actually struck me I
didn't see many weird fish but I saw
something that I felt was very weird I
feel the scientists say no no no it's
normal but we were just going up to a
rock and suddenly a lobster came out
look very much like a lobster just came
out yeah I think it's really interesting
because when we talk about weird things
I think that are different to us and as
where everything is and we live on the
surface of the water most stuff looks
weird to us down there of course it's
just evolved to live in that way and
have that special shape and live in a
certain way because it's underwater so I
don't know what I think weirdest things
I think all things like the angler fish
they're pretty cool because they've got
their own lure so they've got this
little thing that comes off the top of
that head it's often lit up and this
helps attract prey to them that's pretty
neat it's pretty weird Joel who's from
Featherston hi he's got a question for
Mark Austin and the scientists given
their importance why aren't there more
marine reserves well that is a very good
question and a very good question
addressed to a place like this where
something like 50 percent of the sea is
marine reserve and as we were hearing
earlier might be 30 percent soon rowana
why aren't there
reserves well I think if we take the
seychelles context here we can see in
the recent extension of the pre
protected areas but it's really hard
there are so many people who are using
the ocean for a variety of different
uses and to try and get them all to
agree to bring in measures can be really
hard so it's a long process and an
important one but with all these
competing uses we have to find a way to
use that resource sustainably that's
that that's the key I think music yeah
absolutely I think that's a really good
point right you know we're sitting here
now it's a beautiful conservation area
but actually you know there's a lot of
people in their lives and their food
security depends on the ocean so we
can't just say we can't take anything
out we need to do that in a sustainable
manner this does take a lot of
consultation because it only works if
you've got buy-in from everyone who uses
that area but it also takes political
well so something we can help to do as
scientists is provide information what's
out there and what areas can be used
sustainably and what is that sustainable
use but also trained to understand areas
that actually there are so unique and so
important that really as humans we
shouldn't touch them we should be
looking at other areas that maybe might
unregenerate a little quicker
yeah well the ice is a sensitive
sensitive subject of course because
fishermen have their livelihoods and
they have to make a living
let's have a question from Creeper who's
from Featherston hi how many years would
it take to remove all the rubbish from
the ocean well that is a good question
I'm gonna guess and say what you
couldn't do it I don't know what yes
you're right we can't remove all the
rubbish that's being put into the ocean
I mean that's not not possible
some of it is still on the surface of
the water but majority is fragmented and
down at the bottom
so rather than concentrating on the
removal we need to concentrate on
stopping the tap stop it getting into
the ocean that's gonna be the most
success for us and miss that plastic is
really tiny bees that have sunk to the
bottom anyway seabed and in the coral
that's right yeah a lot of its on the
seabed so we just can't remove it it's
amazing pictures Ranna what was your
view it's all about prevention now and
large-scale removal will be an effective
probably at this point and as you said
quite rightly obviously microplastics is
so much more of an issue now that's in
our food chain so it's more about now
stopping that flow of plastics into the
ocean yeah so it's for the next
generation to start looking after the
ocean better than we did maybe back to
you thank you final question from Dawn
and this is for Anna down in the
submersible what is the process for
naming new life if discovered in the
twilight zone and do you bring it to the
surface for further study goodness me I
don't know I don't think there is yet an
arc Austin lobster but I'm sure they'll
be fighting for that as well as the
deepest person ever there to be in this
part of the Indian Ocean certainly and
but certainly one of Lucy's colleagues
at nekton has three things named after
him professor Alex Rogers they're very
interesting interesting animals
certainly but would you like something
named up
I'd love to have something named after
me I don't care what it is it's been
absolutely fascinating experience being
down here I have to say it's wonderful
to hear the questions there from the
schoolchildren it's interesting the
types of questions you're asking is this
is a world that is totally unexplored
that literally nobody knew what was down
here off Aldabra nobody even knew the
shape of the coastline we've been able
to show with the nekton scientists they
the slopes she holds off so steeply as
we can show you there
it is extremely foreboding you look down
and it's a sea of brown inky color and
you literally don't know what's down
there the fish are around us they're
trying to come and say hello there's
still life down here it's critical life
as well because the big question is is
this a refuge if the Seas get warmer and
the cores down here survive can some of
them move into cooler water down here 20
degrees certainly down there
and our Deborah axel itself it is a
world unlike any other there are free
birds flying over there not like
pterosaurs there are giant reptiles
walking along and it is extraordinary to
see the two things together amongst the
best protected part of the world as
grounded here tries to keep us in
position we're swinging around in the
currents because they've come right up
to the rocky outcrop we are now facing
the deep let me show you what we can see
there you go that is the deep ocean
everybody but that is what you're
fighting for there are fish out there
who need the shallows they need the
shallows for juveniles to feed to prey
absolutely crucial deep ocean life has
been an extraordinary experience for me
I hope you've enjoyed it thank you so
much for watching from the deep goodbye
[Music]
ready to go ready to go oh that's so
weird oh look you can see the other self
that's amazing I just can't believe but
we're seeing you and hearing you like
this
[Music]
amazing
same questions about climate change
[Music]
some pretty remote and amazing places in
my time but
[Music]